well surveys show many americans are
itching to travel i know i am
tourism here in las vegas plummeted in
2020 but our city
is bidding on life starting to return to
normal this year wendy gillette shows us
the cobia precautions properties are
taking
to help welcome people back
[Music]
circa in downtown las vegas opened its
hotel a few days before 2021
ushering in a wave of new offerings this
year
on fremont street with a pool
amphitheater and the world's largest
sports book the adults only hotel is the
first newly built downtown resort to
open in four decades
sir richard branson's virgin hotels is
taking over the former hard rock hotel
and plans a late march debut and then
there's resorts
world built from the ground up and
opening this summer on the las vegas
strip
crockfords is one of three hotels along
with a hilton and conrad
that will be part of the 4.3 billion
dollar complex
it's an lxr hotel hilton's newest luxury
brand
it shows the resiliency of las vegas and
it talks about
the desire for travelers to come back to
this great destination when things
are back again to somewhat of a normal
level
until everything is back to normal
safety precautions will remain in place
if you haven't been to vegas lately that
means mandatory face masks and public
spaces
individual properties have their own
measures such as thermal scanners at the
venetian
and at mgm hotels like bellagio there
are plexiglas
barriers at table games contactless
guest experiences
physical distancing policies and more
that you can't see
you can hear our air that's being pumped
in right now that's a very important
part of our protocols
so we're pumping in as much outside
fresh air as possible
mgm's plan also includes a very unusual
site in a casino
custom built hand washing stations with
soap and water
and signs reminding people about the
importance of washing your hands
during the pandemic brunell says only 19
million tourists visited las vegas last
year
down 55 percent from 2019.
so what's your hope for 2021 well our
hope for 2021
is that as we hit march april may june
and frankly as we get into the third
quarter that there will be enough
vaccinations as well as individuals that
have recovered from
the virus that we will see a good amount
of herd immunity he's hoping soon that
will be a sure
bet wendy gillette cbs news las vegas
some more good news for you there are
two new residencies planned to usher at
caesars and donny osmond
at harris very exciting news there well
when it comes to opening
uh this summer resorts world will have a
new partner in shopping and of course
and in entertainment the resort has
teamed up with la retailer fred siegel
for a new retail district it's set to
bring some
l.a style food and culture right here to
las vegas